il avait 18 ans un jeune de traînel venu
jouer au foot sur la base militaire de
deux est tué d'une balle le 1er juillet
quarante ans plus tard c'est la première
fois que la famille et ses amis
reviennent sur les lieux du drame
ils se souviennent de ce jour là le
drame s'est passé exactement ici l'on se
trouve et le tireur était bloqué dans
l'une des fenêtres là là c'était la
cuisine ce qu'on appelle en langage de
langage familier l'ordinaire c'est l'un
de tes os ou terre et c'est là à l'est a
été touché le tireur un caporal chef
christian richerol du même âge que sa
victime il aurait tiré plusieurs coups
de feu en direction des jeunes jusqu'à
atteindre alain gignac
à l'époque c'était chose courante pour
les jeunes de traînel que de venir
profiter de la pelouse a rappelé le
député letchimy invités on venait chaque
chacun avec sa bouteille d'eau qu'on me
portais dans la mer pieds nus parce
qu'on n'avait pas d'argent pour rester 2
la chaussure de football et quand on
avait une paire de tennis était un
miracle et de la sont sortis
certainement les meilleurs joueurs de
l'alaric et un homme a été abattu
alain gignac décédera avant son arrivée
à l'hôpital
sa compagne était enceinte de deux
semaines et me disais il ya ceux qui à
90 ans pour moi même si c'est un garçon
ca moyen si c'est une fille ça moi et
cela les a fière je le disais me disait
fais attention pas très chaud mais un
essai ses amis hétéros comment j'étais
un nouveau cesse jamais connu mon père
du monde
vous étiez au courant de tout ça oui oui
je trouverai je connaissais l'histoire
des deux côtés c'est à dire que quand on
est enfant on a une famille qui nous
raconte quelque chose comme dans tout en
veut toujours savoir entendre les 200
cloche ce crime contrairement à tant
d'autres de cette époque ne restera pas
impuni
le tireur sera condamné à neuf ans de
prison et c'est peut-être cette justice
qui a permis ce matin à la famille de
passer à l'armée un message qu'elle
n'attendait sûrement pas 40 ans et pas
quarante jours c'est pas 40 semaines
c'est fait donc ces deux familles qui
sont en souffrance jusqu'à maintenant
nous n'avons pas à juger ne la sait
comment ça s'est passé ne la sait
pourquoi l'armée sans aucune jeune
j'allais du gange à vous m
ce sont toujours vous tél et j'aime tout
le monde c'est pas grave c'est fait le
décès du jeune alain gignac avait
soulevé à l'époque la colère des foules
quarante ans plus tard c'est dans le
pardon et la dignité que sa mémoire a
été honoré
[Musique]